one of the things that's happened
recently of course it was the change in
Saudi Arabia with Mohammed bin Salman
taking over he seems to be a whole new
creature if I can put it that way and
part of maybe a broader thing that we'll
talk about which is the emergence of
these very strong men generally men
leaders around the world what do you
make of him and the impact that he might
have on on the Middle East well he is
having a major impact in many respects
many different ways so within Saudi
Arabia he is leading a push towards
greater social liberalisation but at the
same time he has and is behaved and
behaving like a medieval monarch the
Saudi Arabia's mint is a medieval
country so it's been important to
understand that then you know not judge
it by any Western standards because
they're just not relevant so if you know
your history in Britain France and so on
your medieval British history with King
Henry's and John and Richard and you
know the stuff so you had a king who was
sometimes strongest on this weekend you
had barons and Lords and so around the
country and each of these guys are in
here and their own fief and the medieval
system and the king would try to get
taxes
in terms of money in terms of produce
and even if he needed to go to war then
he would say you know you got a surprise
how many many and you might say it
wasn't the King Randor whole country it
was very much decentralized and if you
apply that model to sword rebel you have
some understanding of what's going on
right he even though he is the king he
has difficulty imposing his ideas on the
entire royal family which is a very
large and complex
group of people and beyond that there
are many there are tribes and these
tribal units together comprise the saw
the army and the Armed Forces and there
are business entities business groups
one of the most famous is have been
Loudoun family you decided not to pursue
a business career went in a different
direction but they are very big
commercially oriented family you know
nothing to do with terrorism estimate so
Saudi Arabia's very complex place and he
is trying to wrench it out of where it
was socially and particularly
economically reliance on oil and so on
and force in a different direction and
that is very difficult to do in a very
conservative country and and he's doing
this whilst being whilst being engaged
in what is a very deep-seated struggle
against Iran and Shiite Islam and he's
doing it with the American defense
umbrella and a fading away and so he has
enormous problems apart from those
stemming from the fact that he's young
and immature and so his objective
problems
[Music]